premier budget Morneau le voici il est
peut-être un petit peu plus mince que
prévu mais il est quand même dense en
contenu d'abord ce que vous voulez
savoir c'est la grosseur du déficit 29
mliards 400 millions pour 2016-207 avec
des déficit dans les prochaines années
les libéraux ne chiffrent pas le retour
à l'équilibre budgétaire cinq choses que
vous devez savoir l'entrée en vigueur de
laallocation canadienne pour enfants qui
vient remplacer toutes les autres
prestations qui vient annuler également
le fractionnement de revenus des
conjoints des couples avec enfants ça va
rapporter en moyenne aux familles par
enfant 2300 dollars par année
bonification également de l'assurance
emploi avec le délai de carence qui sera
plus court une semaine on ajoute 5
semaines de chômage dans les régions où
le chômage est élevé on pense à
l'Alberta et terneuve surtout et puis la
baisse du taux de cotisation à
l'assurance emploi sera moins prononcé
que ce que les conservateurs avaient
prévu bonification du supplément de
revenu garantie pour les années si vous
avez un revenu de moins de 4600 dollars
par année en excluant votre Supplément
de revenu garanti en excluant votre
pension de vieillesse vous avez droit à
un supplément de revenu garanti plus
généreux 947 dollars de plus 120
milliards de dollars sur 10 ans dans les
infrastructures donc on vient doubler le
budget des infrastructures avec un
accent prononcé sur le transport en
commun d'ailleurs dans les transports
dans le transport en commun les projets
recevables seront payés à 50 % par le
gouvernement fédéral et puis de l'argent
en éducation formation enfance
infrastructure chez les Autochtones une
enveloppe de 8illard 400 millions de
dollars sur 5 ans premier budget mornoau
ambitieux euh mais qui soulève de
certaines questions je vous dirais sur
le retour à l'équilibre budgétaire